[Música]
cada día 20 niños en promedio sufren las
consecuencias directas de Las Guerras
que hay en el mundo según unicef se
estima que los menores de edad han
padecido al menos 300.000 violaciones a
sus derechos Durante los conflictos
armados que se han registrado en el
mundo en los últimos 18 años y el número
podría ser mayor
en Brasil el presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva aprovechó el Día Mundial
del medio ambiente para presentar su
plan con el que pretende frenar la
deforestación entre otras medidas el
proyecto establece la posibilidad de
embarcar el 50% de las tierras que han
sido deforestadas de forma ilegal
Mike pence se unirá a la carrera por la
Casa Blanca el ex vicepresidente de
Estados Unidos tendrá que competir junto
a su antiguo compañero de Fórmula Donald
Trump por ser el candidato del partido
republicano que se enfrente a Joe biden
en las presidenciales de 2024
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz
el fondo de las Naciones Unidas para la
infancia unicef manifestó en un informe
que existe una media de 20 niños por día
que sufren directamente las
consecuencias de Las Guerras en todo el
mundo desde 2005 la ONU verificó
315,000 violaciones graves en que
incluyen muertes mutilaciones secuestros
y hasta reclutamiento forzado sin
embargo estima que la cifra es
robustamente superior dado que solamente
se cuentan casos corroborados
cada día en los últimos 18 años una
media de 20 niños han sido asesinados o
mutilados en medio de Las Guerras en
todo el mundo la ONU ha verificado
315,000 violaciones graves contra
Menores en conflicto desde 2015 las
cifras forman parte de un abrumadora
informe de unicef que muestra el alcance
del impacto de la guerra y los
conflictos en los niños
la guerra es algo terrible pero la
guerra es cosa de adultos y los adultos
deben como mínimo proteger a los niños
en el transcurso de los conflictos el
informe desglosa las violaciones en
categorías incluidos los niños muertos o
mutilados los reclutados por las fuerzas
armadas los secuestrados y los sometidos
a violencia sexual y lo que es aún más
alarmante solo se trata de los casos
verificados por lo que la cifra real es
probablemente mucho mayor mientras los
líderes se reúnen en oslo para debatir
sobre la protección de la infancia
unicef insta a los gobiernos a dar un
paso adelante y asumir nuevos
compromisos Ah creo que es importante
que como comunidad internacional digamos
que no aceptamos la impunidad que
pensamos que estas personas son
responsables en lo que hacen que no es
inevitable que esto ocurra en la guerra
sino que ocurre porque la gente cree que
puede salirse con la suya y no sabe lo
que hace y creo que debemos intentar que
rindan cuentas la magnitud de los
riesgos a los que se enfrentan los niños
en las zonas de conflicto no se
corresponde con la financiación
disponible un análisis encargado por
unicef predice un déficit de mil
millones de dólares para 2026
financiación necesaria para apoyar
servicios críticos como la reunificación
familiar el apoyo a la Salud Mental y la
prevención de reclutamiento por parte de
grupos armados este 5 de junio se
conmemoró el Día Mundial del medio
ambiente y el presidente Luis Ignacio
lulada Silva en Brasil aprovechó la
fecha para anunciar medidas para acabar
con la deforestación en la amazonía de
aquí a 2030 este proyecto es una versión
actualizada de un programa creado
durante su primera administración en
2004 pero que había sido descontinuado
por su antecesor Jair bolsonaro entre el
paquete de medidas se contempla la
posibilidad de embargar el 50% de las
tierras que han sido deforestadas de
forma ilegal
principalmente debido a la selva
amazónica Brasil es en gran parte
responsable del equilibrio climático
mundial por eso de tener la
deforestación en la amazonía también es
una forma de reducir el calentamiento
global
sede de la magnitud del desafío
determinar con la deforestación para
2030 pero este es un desafío que estamos
decididos a lograr con las medidas que
anunciamos hoy y más que se anunciarán y
se adaptarán más adelante
Y a propósito del Día Mundial del medio
ambiente en Chile los casos de
enfermedades respiratorias en los
ciudadanos de Santiago capital del país
van en aumento algunos miembros de la
comunidad médica han atribuido esta
situación a la pobre calidad del aire en
la ciudad la cual sería una de las
peores del continente según un estudio
realizado en colaboración con Naciones
Unidas el informe es de Max Pérez
Gallardo
Esta es la capital más contaminada de
América Latina según un informe
realizado por la compañía Suiza iq Air
en cooperación con el programa de
Naciones Unidas para el medio ambiente
situado como la capital con la peor
calidad de aire en la región el ranking
se mide por cuantas micropartículas
pm2,5 existen en el aire originadas de
la quema de combustibles fósiles e
incendios naturales y son comúnmente
causantes de enfermedades respiratorias
pero tienen la capacidad de poder
ingresar al tracto respiratorio y
producir cierto grado de inflamación el
hecho de que la vías respiratoria ya
esté en con cierto grado de inflamación
hace que las defensas para los virus que
puedan haber en esta época circulando
disminuye por lo tanto aumenta la
posibilidad de infección respiratoria
producto de los virus un informe de la
prestigiosa revista médica de lanced
ubica a Chile como el país
latinoamericano con mortalidad
atribuible a la contaminación del aire
con 250 muertes por cada millón de
habitantes al año el gobierno chileno ha
expresado su preocupación sobre las
complicaciones respiratorias en sus
ciudadanos Nosotros hemos estado
preocupados y ocupados del tema de la
infección con virus respiratoria hemos
estado viendo estas últimas semanas un
alto número de casos de virus
respiratorio esencial con cuadros graves
en niños menores debido a la creciente
contaminación la salud de los habitantes
de Santiago empeora cada vez más en
Canadá aumenta la preocupación por los
incendios en casi todo el país de Cara a
la temporada veraniega las autoridades
informaron este lunes que el país se
enfrenta a una temporada de incendios
especialmente grave debido a que se
espera condiciones excepcionalmente
cálidas y secas hasta el final del
verano las llamas ya han alcanzado
también el este del país y han obligado
a evacuar la provincia atlántica de
Nueva Escocia y la costa de Quebec
nuestro modelo muestra que esta puede
ser una temporada de incendios
forestales especialmente se grabe
durante todo el verano vamos a superar
esto juntos nuestro gobierno seguirá
estando allí con lo que sea necesario
para mantener a las personas seguras y
brindar apoyo el ex vicepresidenta
republicano Mike pence inscribió su
candidatura para las elecciones
presidenciales de Estados Unidos de 2024
ofreciendo una alternativa
tradicionalista a la batalla que también
librando Donald Trump y ron de santis el
Cristiano evangélico presentó la
documentación ante la Comisión Federal
de elecciones antes de una declaración
oficial que se espera para este
miércoles en el estado de Iowa más
detalles en el siguiente informe en su
camino hacia la carrera presidencial
Mike pence ha lanzado oficialmente su
nombre alrededor como candidato
republicano para las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 el político de 63
años presentó la documentación que
declara su campaña y se espera un
anuncio formal el miércoles en Iowa
tengo que decirles que Durante los
últimos dos años Karen y yo hemos pasado
mucho tiempo refl exionando y llorando
sobre todo lo que está pasando en este
país y lo que podríamos hacer para
servir y no tengo nada que anunciar hoy
pero puedo decirles Cuando tenga tiempo
para anunciar este miércoles lo
anunciaré en Iowa
su mayor rival por supuesto será Donald
Trump quien fue su jefe cuando se
desempeñó como vicepresidente entre 2017
y 2021 pens fue un fiel defensor del
presidente durante esos cuatro años pero
se ha distanciado desde el asalto de Los
partidarios de Trump al Capitolio de los
Estados Unidos en enero de 2021 Trump
había presionado a pense para anular la
victoria electoral de Joe biden algo a
lo que él se negó Durante los hechos
algunos manifestantes pedían colgar a
pence mientras asaltaban los pasillos
del Congreso por lo que muchos
seguidores de Trump lo ven como un
traidor pence es solo otro nombre para
agregar a una lista cada vez mayor de
candidatos republicanos Allí se incluye
al gobernador de Florida ron de santis
quien has visto como el contendiente más
cercano de Trump así como la
exgobernadora de Carolina del Sur Nicky
Halley muchos expertos describen Esta
carrera por la nominación republicana
como una de las más derechistas que ha
visto el partido en Argentina la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández fue
desvinculada de un caso en el que se le
investigaba por presunto lavado de
dinero al ex mandataria se le vinculaba
con el empresario Lázaro báez quien Tuvo
una estrecha relación con el matrimonio
kirchner y fue condenado a 10 años de
prisión por el blanqueo de más de 50
millones de dólares la causa era
conocida como la ruta del dinero k y se
había abierto desde 2013 cuando
Fernández era presidente
cerramos en silicon Valley Apple se suma
a la carrera de la realidad aumentada
con el lanzamiento de sus nuevas gafas
visión Pro en palabras del director
ejecutivo de la compañía Team Cook este
producto permitirá al usuario
interactuar con un contenido digital
como si existiera en un espacio físico
las Vision Pro estarán disponibles a
principios de próximo año en Estados
Unidos y llegarán a más países a partir
de 2024
hasta aquí este Informativo en frases 24
Gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos a
que continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]